one of our value is nature knows best we
use things that have been around for
millions of years rather than
introducing very new synthetic things
that we have no feedback from nature on
but
going to be more Plastics than fish in
our ocean inner not plot the alternative
to single-use Plastics let's take a look
[Music]
not play the team of chemists Engineers
designers entrepreneurs we're developing
new solutions that try to use seaweed
instead of plastic for a lot of
single-use applications typically
packaging for food service electronic
products lots of things that we consume
really quickly and packaging is thrown
away we started with Ojo which is a
little bubble that can contain water or
liquids where we found a really good
application for marathons festivals
places where there is a big consumption
in a very short amount of time and where
in a way there is the highest chance of
littering there is no waste if you don't
eat it nature will eat it and that was
really our starting point into this uh
this journey you said nature Canada how
long does it take for it to go away so
typically it takes four to six weeks but
actually it can take as little as 10
days in our warmery where we test things
side by side breaks down faster than the
P11 orange you mentioned you know this
this hatchets and then you have some
other uses for them we started to put a
lot of different things in the machine
see what happens and that's when we
realized that actually it could be a
really good solution for condiments we
developed these ketchup sachets and
actually realize with our partner just
did that we were still sending them in
plastic boxes so the next challenge was
what do we do about the box and so we
started to realize that we didn't have
to just make one product but we could
create like a catalog of different
solutions what was it that Drew you
towards focusing on Ocean blast yeah I
think it was just one of our kind of
like interests like why can't we make
things more like nature and I think when
we realized that if these things are
going to end up in the ocean we could
solve the problem by having something
that actually belongs to the ocean
anyway that was something that was
really interesting
and when you think about it everything
started in the ocean so seaweed have
been there for such a long time because
of its diversity there's about 12 000
species of seaweed all with their own
like DNA makeup very different
um some species of seaweed are more
different than a mushroom and a bear
like that's the spectrum that you've got
when you look at seaweed
some of the seaweed grow very fast so
some of the seaweed we've tried in the
lab grow up to a meter per day so it's
one of the fastest growing organisms on
the planet when you look at it like it
also has a lot of added value compared
to things that grow on land it doesn't
require fresh water it doesn't require
any fertilizer and it's really a zero
input crop you just like Let It Grow you
can't micromanage it like we do with
agriculture on land
because seaweed becomes more
industrialized is there is there a
responsible way to farm it or to take it
from the open oceans so that's the great
advantage of farming is that you can
bring additional seaweed in places where
it's maybe kind of like disappeared
because we've messed with the
environment but there's lots of dead
zones where water doesn't mix nutrients
doesn't flow and there's not much life
in those parts of the ocean and seaweed
can be the first actor to start restart
reboot that system and bring back that
diversity so awesome well thank you I'm
gonna go down to your lab and chat to
Louise who's going to teach me a little
bit more about seaweed Louise hi Matthew
so can you show me what's going on here
what are we gonna look at so I'm going
to show you how we actually make the
coating that goes inside our box so I
can show you the process over here
we get all the powders together we can
then blend it into a mixture with water
and this creates kind of a formulation
that allows us to coat it evenly on the
material on the paper
it's kind of like glue yeah yeah a
little bit and it's quite sticky
and this is kind of a demonstration of
basically how it's done on industry so
this is how we do on the lab scale of it
so how how would this work in like the
bigger bigger machines so there's lots
of different coating processes there's
one which uses this Rod which is called
a mayor bar coating but there's also
like loads of other methods so we're
currently looking at three different
methods that we're scaling up cool so
can you show me more of this maybe and
the product view so we can check out the
products and maybe discuss a little bit
more about the science and the chemistry
behind them yeah definitely you can show
them upstairs all right let's go thanks
so we're in the design studio can you
give me a little bit about what we just
looked at downstairs and like actually
how it works on the product yep so we
take that coating we convert it into a
box so it depends on what the customer
wants we've got a takeaway box here
we've also got seaweed paper which is
actually using waste product from our
extraction process that's what I can see
in the paper too yeah so this is a waste
fiber from the process of extracting the
seaweed component that we use to make
our Ojo and also our Coatings so we
actually found these waste fibers were
really useful to incorporate into paper
and reduce the dependency on virgin wood
this is another type of waste fiber from
the Milling process or you can also make
sachets and some of these are water
soluble as well so we can actually drop
them into water and they'll fully
degrade cool can I see one of those yeah
oh wow yeah it's funny what you
experience with plastic and how your
mind kind of thinks it's going to feel
it's totally different when it comes to
Natural materials and the Ojos
themselves are also quite squishy and
quite fun so we can test one of those if
you want sure okay so she bite a bit off
there's a little little soup slurp there
[Music]